how do you avoid
um being distracted by because i haven't
seen
like very successful men uh like jeff
those
those those millionaire billionaire who
are single or
you know still spinning plate they
usually have a woman
with them so how do you
you know stop i'm single so i i
i find that going trying to chase
excellence
and um of course i want to have a woman
you know
it's a little distracting yeah so i mean
you're asking like
how are all these billionaires you know
like with these women like how does that
work for them sort of thing
yeah i can tell you because they suck
with women yeah i can tell you right now
i mean like if you take a look at the
richest people in the world you got uh
jeff bezos he's a [ __ ] idiot you know
he left his uh
you know he basically screwed up his
marriage by banging some
homewrecker you know essentially um
bill uh gates he doesn't wear the pants
in that relationship she does
he's still a [ __ ] beta idiot smart as
hell i mean he made a ton of money and
he created one of the biggest companies
in the world but
i wouldn't i wouldn't try to say oh you
know i'd love to have bill gates
marriage or i wouldn't you know
i'd want to have jeff bezos life or i'd
want to be like
elon musk have you seen his [ __ ]
third wife or fourth wife or whatever
she is
yeah it looks like she fell out of a
goth club drunk
he's really an alpha no no he's a
successful businessman
okay he is not he is not a red bull
alpha well not with women though so you
gotta understand dude like
i i gotta do a i gotta do i'm doing a
video on this probably next week here
because
i've had a couple of blue check marks
and some people who are very
high level guys with going holy crap
dude i need some help here
recently become my clients and um
there here's the trap their smv
gets to be so high with women and their
opportunity
gets to be so much that they think that
that
mat that they they think that they have
a level of skill
but they don't see the quality of your
relationships with women in your life is
a function of your smv
your skill with women which is your game
and then your opportunity
so some of these celebrities and high
you know high earners
like your elon musk's a g dude of course
he's a boss
but he doesn't have the skill with women
with
vetting with selection and i
i'll bet with maintain maintaining
because these are things you have to
actually work on
musk has been married to the same chick
twice he's been divorced three times
and now he's got a chick with a not a
chick he's got a kid with this
chick who freaked out on him because he
said take the red pill on
on on twitter not only did she freak out
him but her mommy freaked out on him
as well elon if you're watching
you would we would be on mars you book
me for coaching
i'll [ __ ] sort out your life buddy
i'm telling you right now
we will we will get people off earth and
to mars
once i get you focused on your purpose
and away from making stupid choices of
the women okay all right thank you guys
i appreciate you guys are doing a really
good job out there um
so just i i wish i had known about this
10 years ago you got it brother take
care all right
thanks bro
you